hello and welcome to section 5 features
so we now finish talking about what a predictor is
and how one evaluates predictors and we can start
to move on by talking about how to construct
predictors and the first step in the process
is taking the data in its raw form and
embedding it into vectors and i'm going
to establish a little bit more with a little
bit more formality right now exactly how we do
that and talk about a variety of different ways in
which we embed data in vector space so that we can
use mathematical techniques to construct
predictors we have raw data pairs which we
will denote by u and v where u is in some script u
which is the set of possible u's and v is in some
script with v the set of possible v's and here
script u is the set of all possible input values
and script v is the set of all possible output
values and ideally our predictor is going to take
an element of script u and return
for us an element of script v
the elements of u are called records and
typically they're a list of attributes
of the data um these attributes these
which will index the uis are called
fields or components of the data and notice
here the i here is a subscript on you when
we use a superscript that means the ice record
when we use a subscript that means the ice field
of a record and each of these fields has a type
it might be a real number it might be a boolean
it could be one of several different
types it could be a piece of text
could be audio it could be an image it could
be a parse tree an output of a compiler
there are also certain generic
types that we talk about categorical
in ordinal types and i will tell you what those
are shortly um so for example you might have a um
the set u be a set of houses and uh
and then a record would record the properties
of um a house so it might give us its address a
photo of the house perhaps some photos of inside
the house a description which is a piece of text
a categorization of it as either a
house or an apartment the size of a lot
the number of bedrooms and so on the list goes on
um our goal with all of these things is that we're
given all of this data and we're trying to predict
say the price how much did the house sell for
should the house sell for and notice that each
of these fields of the description of a house
has a type so address well that might
be text or we might be a little bit more
uh precise about what an address is it might be
a have a street number and a street name and a
city and a county we might have gps
coordinates for the location of the house
the description is is text but even there we
might be able to be a little bit more refined
about that we might have description
of various parts of the house we might
have standard forms for the description of
the house and so how we take this data and
embed it in vector space is going to affect a lot
our ability to make useful predictions using it
so abstractly the uh the functions that we use to
do this embedding are called the feature maps and
we have two of them one of them takes u and embeds
it in d-dimensional vector space and gives us
x one of them the other one takes v and
embeds that in m-dimensional vector space
and gives us y and learning algorithms are
applied to x y pairs which are just vectors
and the functions are called phi and psi so phi
takes a u and gives us an x and psi takes a v
and gives us a y and these are the feature
maps they transform data records into vectors
usually feature maps work on the separate
fields so we'll have a feature map that maps the
photograph into a vector space we have a feeder
feature map that maps the address into a vector
space and so we've really got a different
feature map for each of the different fields
of a particular record and um and then
we'll construct one feature map which takes
uh the entire record and maps that into a
vector space and the way it does it is by
mapping each of the fields of the record into
each of their component vector spaces and then
joining up all the vectors into one long
vector so phi subscript i is an embedding
it's if it's uh it's a map which takes field
i into a vector and the overall function phi
is the feature map that combines all these
embeddings and takes a record into a vector
the the reason we do this is so that we
can put all the different field types
on an equal footing they're all vectors
and some some of these embeddings are very very
simple so if the raw data is actually just a
real number such as the uh the lot size of the
house then we might just embed it by using the
identity map we'll just embed it according
to x it's equal to u um uh sometimes uh uh
a field may be boolean um and so for example uh
uh it might be uh uh for a house it might be
has a pool and the answer could be yes or no
and uh in which case we would map that to a real
number in a vector space by saying 1 if the answer
is yes and minus 1 if the answer is no or we
might map it according to 1 if yes and 0 if no
uh color um we might map to uh three numbers
uh the amount of red the amount of green
uh the amount of blue and uh that's a very typical
encoding for color which we use a lot for images
but it's by no means the only one and uh there
are quite a few different standard color encodings
um there are also much more sophisticated
encodings which we will have a
chance to talk about later
so one is this one has a text
document and one wants to
embed that as a vector then there's a map
called the tfidf map that stands for term
frequency inverse document frequency and we'll
see exactly what that is and why it's useful for
learning properties of text building predictors
for text another one for text is called
word to back we'll see that in just a second that
maps individual words into vectors rather than
mapping hold documents into vectors um another
one is that instead of thinking about an image
as a collection of pixels we use a particular
feature map to map the image into vectors
and these are pre-trained neural networks and
we will see uh an example of this for shortly
one of the things we want out of
an embedding is that it should be
faithful and what that means is that it should
somehow preserve similarity so if you and utilde
are two different records but somehow they're
similar they correspond to two similar houses
then when we embed them we get a phi of u and
we get a phi of utilda and those two vectors
should be close to each other in the vector space
and conversely if phi of u is not near 5u tilde
well then u and utilda should be dissimilar
houses and so the the geometry and the distances
within our vector space should somehow correspond
to our intuitive notions of similarity for our
underlying raw data and this particular notion
of similarity well it depends on the application
that we have in mind it depends on the field type
that we're looking at for houses we have some idea
of what that means they should be similar size
they should be similar quality of construction
they should be similar types of houses similar
numbers of bedrooms we have some idea of what
that means and for many other things it won't
be so obvious as to what it means in any
numerical sense but it might be obvious
in an intuitive sense we know that for example two
images that are both images of cats are similar to
each other but they're distinct from an image of a
dog and that's something that we're going to have
trouble quantifying we'll see there are
texts there are ways of um embedding in uh
in such a way as to have a faithful representation
of such things and we will get to those
so there are lots of interesting examples one
might think about where it's not so obvious
how to construct a faithful embedding
we can think about names of people
professions companies countries
languages zip codes cities songs movies
and we're going to see several of these and
examples and we'll also see some generic
general techniques for constructing
embeddings here's one suppose you have uh
location data you have the position of something
on the world um so you might describe that
by two numbers the latitude and longitude
that would give us a two-dimensional vector in r2
or you might say really this should be embedded
in r3 we think about the the world as a
globe and the globe is has a natural
embedding in three-dimensional space and so
we can embed our position in on the surface of
the globe as a position on the sphere in our sv
maybe that makes more sense if your
data points are spread over the planet
here's another example the day of the week um so
we have monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday sunday we could just enable label them
one through seven and that would be a an embedding
we should embed them uh by the day of the
week into a one-dimensional vector space
also on this slide we see a two-dimensional vector
space this is interesting this is useful because
for many types of data the similarity between days
is that a day is similar to the day before and
a day after and um if we were to embed monday as
one and tuesday wednesday thursday friday saturday
sunday is seven then one and seven would be quite
far apart and so monday and sunday would be quite
far apart if we embed them like this so here
we've embedded them as seven points in our r2
well then we can see that the distance between
monday and tuesday and the distance between
monday and sunday those two distances are the
same and indeed the distance between any two
consecutive days is uh is the same and so
this is an embedding that more faithfully
captures that idea and we can do that for lots
of different notions of time we can do that for
um months of the year which you might
embed as 12 points we can do that for hours
of the day which we might embed around the
circle that's 12 points around the circle
now here's a more sophisticated example this
is a word to beg and that's a mapping on words
so you give the here the field type is a
word a word in the english language and um
words to vec for each word in the english
language you map it will map it to a vector
and that vector is a 300 dimensional vector
um and so where to beg actually will work on
words and short phrases it doesn't just include
dictionary words but it also includes names
of people and names of places and many other
things and it's developed from a data set which
comes from google news which contains 100 billion
words and so this is not a hand constructed
embedding or hand constructed feature map this is
an automatically constructed embedding and we will
say more about how that is done later in the class
the principal idea here is that words that
frequently appear near each other should get
nearby vectors and um ah so we might look at that
now of course it's hard to look at the specific
vectors that correspond to where to vect because
um they're 300 dimensional so we can't plot them
but of course we can use them for all sorts
of predictor construction however here we
can we can just plot some of their components
so here are two of their components x1 and x2
of a bunch of different words
let's zoom in a bit here
and so you can see even when you look at a
two-dimensional projection of this 300 dimensional
vector space you can see that words that sort of
mean similar things are kind of close together
uh let's look here we've got uh optimistic
let's see if i can make that a bit smaller
we've got optimistic proud enthusiastic happy
satisfied eager interested amazed these are all
kind of next to each other down here uh we've also
got uh melancholy sorrow hostile bitter awkward
guilty anguished hopeless vengeful lonely what
kind of negative words sitting at the top there
we've got some others we've got some uh irritated
exasperated angry embarrassed frustrated scared
all of these kind of similar words over there and
so here are these are just a selection of words
these are the emotion words of course there are uh
three million words in the database um and this is
just a two-dimensional projection but nonetheless
one can see the what it does in terms of grouping
there are also some interesting properties of word
to vec some nice other types of faithfulness of
the data that comes out for example if i take the
vector for king and subtract the vector for man
and then i add the vector for woman
then the closest vector that i get to the result
is the vector for queen similarly if i take
rome and subtract italy and add france
then the closest vector i get is paris
and so these kinds of things are somewhat
surprising properties of the embedding that
are quite magical but illustrate the point that
somehow the embedding is capturing the
structure of the relationship between words
um which is uh what's going to enable it to
be useful when we actually use it for learning
let's turn now to a sophisticated method of
embedding image data and uh this is uh called
vgg16 so imagenet is an open database of images
it contains about 14 million labeled images
in about a thousand different classes
and they range over all sorts of
different things they include many images
of animals of vehicles of everyday objects
shoes that's
a very broad collection of images
but they've all been labeled and so
we know exactly what is in each of those images
so vgg16 is an embedding which maps images um
to a vector in rd and here d is 4096. so we
get a 4096 long vector and the images that we
start with are all cropped down to 224 by 224
pixels their color so they have rgb components
and that is uh some uh 150 160 odd thousand
components 160 odd uh components of each
image and we have three numbers per pixel and so
we're going from what we might think of as a as a
vector in 160 000 dimensions and we're mapping
it down to a vector in 40 96 dimensions
and vgg16 it's a neural network
and it was originally developed to
classify the images and so it learned from the
imagenet database the uh a way of mapping images
to labels but it's also been repurposed as
a general method of constructing a feature
map it's a general method of embedding images
in vector space now this particular neural
network has 16 layers and its input is an
image and its output is the vector in r4096
let's look at what it looks like so here are
six different uh images they're each 224 by 224
image one is simply the ubuntu mug 2 and
3 are some guy image 4 is professor steven
boyd image 5 is a car it happens to be a a mini
traveler edition from the 1960s and the image
6 is a london bus for those of you who haven't
yet figured out for my accent i am english and
this particular car is actually exactly the same
type of car my family drove about in when i was
10 years old and this is exactly the
kind of london bus that i would have
ridden on back in those days
although the car that we had was
blue not green um so let's take these
images um and embed them under the vgg16
map and for each one of them we're going to get
a 4096 long vector and what we've done here is uh
com looked at it looked at those images in pairs
and for each pair of images computed the distance
in terms of the euclidean norm between
the two corresponding embedded vectors
so let's look at this embedding the matrix
here is a matrix of the pairwise distances
between the embedded vectors of each of the
images so for example this number right here
is the 2 3 entry of the matrix and so that's
the distance between image 2 and image 3.
both of which are images of me and so we expect
them to be close if this is a faithful embedding
if we compare that distance between with the
distance between image two and image five well
then suddenly we're looking at the a number of 109
compared to 63 which is substantially different
and we can see that the two images of me are
rather close to each other whereas image 2 is
quite far from an image of a mini and same for
the distance between an image of me and uh the
image of the bus those are also quite far apart
and the same is true for the other images of me
image three to image five and image three
to image six are also quite far apart
uh and if we compare Stephen to the the bus and the
car he's also quite distinct from a bus and a car
however the distance between image 2 and image 4
we're both people those are both head shots we
can see that those numbers are quite a lot smaller
than the corresponding distances between
humans and people if we compare image
three and four that's the other image of
me and Stephen they're also quite close
well there's one more interesting
pair that's comparing the vehicles
so that's this number right here that's the
distance between image five and image six
so that's this distance right there and we can see
that the two vehicles are considered much closer
at 86 than a vehicle in any person
which are all about a hundred
so this image this embedding is
faithful uh we can also look at the um
the uh the images of the mug you
can see that the images of the mug
are all quite far
from all the other images in
terms of euclidean norm distance
and so we can say well this is a reasonably
faithful embedding it's it's it's surprisingly
effective at figuring out that three
faces are kind of similar to each other
two vehicles are kind of similar
to each other but faces are really
different from vehicles and mugs are different
from faces and mugs are different from vehicles
notice here that we didn't give it data that it
had been developed for we i picked these images
from uh some other source none of these images are
as far as i know on image on imagenet and so here
we're repurposing uh a trained set of features
and we're using effectively different images
and that sort of idea where one takes
a model that has been developed using a
particular data set and then uses it for a
different learning task is called transfer
learning
now we usually assume that an embedding is
standardized that's not always the case but
it is very often the case and certainly when we
construct embeddings by hand we go out of our
way to make sure they're standardized what
that means is that they're centered around
zero and they have an rms value around one and
of course that means for a particular data set
we take all of the records u in a data set and
uh we look at the we take each of them and embed
them under phi so we get a whole bunch of phi
u's which is a bunch of vectors and that set
of vectors should be centered around zero and that
set of vectors should have an rms value around one
um and so that means that roughly the entries of
five u range between plus and minus 1 very roughly
and with standard embeddings that means
that if i've embedded each of these features
phi 1 up to phi r here into to have this
property that they're all centered around 0
and have rms value around 1 that means
they're all comparable a large value of
x1 which is phi 1 of u1 and a large value of x2
phi 2 of u2 will both be around 1 or 2 and a small
value will both be around minus 1 or minus two
um and it means that we can compare them we don't
need to worry about what units the original data
u1 and u2 was in or what magnitude they naturally
have we've normalized and we might measure the
distance between two embedded vectors using the
rms and so we take the rms of the vector 5u minus
phi of utilda that's a reasonable measure of how
close records you and you today are that's again
a consequence of the faithfulness of the embedding
and so the way we ensure that all of our data has
this property that is centered at zero and has
uh values that range between plus and minus
one you do what's called standardization
it's also called z scoring um so suppose
we've got real numbers in the the field type
and then we've got u1 through
un which are real numbers
uh then what we might do is we
might define u bar to be the
average of the uis and stood u to be the standard
deviation of the use and then in order to
construct uh a vector or in this case a scalar x
which is an embedding of u which is normalized we
do what's called the z-score transformation where
we take u subtract it from subtract from it u bar
and then divide by the standard deviation
and that ensures that first of all
that the average of the x's is zero
and the standard deviation of the x's is one
so these are very easy to
interpret all of a sudden
if i've got uh z scored features and i
look at x when i see an x which is 1.3
well that means that the corresponding u is one
point three standard deviations above the mean
now another transformation we might do be
uh before z-scoring is taking the log now
this is a very standard rule of thumb if
you've got a field u which is a positive
number but it ranges over a very wide scale
then you embed it as phi of u is equal to log
of u sometimes you'll use log of one plus u if u
is allowed to be zero and then your standardized
so for example if u is the amount of traffic
that a particular website receives well then
you've got a bunch of different websites
and each one has a different amount of
traffic and there is a huge difference
between the amount of traffic that the
big websites like amazon and google
receive and then rather smaller websites
such as my own website receives and these
are many many orders of magnitude different
and so uh with this kind of thing it's much
better to instead of trying to uh look at
numbers over such a wide range of scales to take
the logs and then we might conclude that well
a thousand and eleven hundred are very
similar 20 and 22 are also very similar
um but 20 and 120 are not similar if we were to
measure those in absolute terms we might say well
20 and 120 are a hundred apart and a thousand
and eleven hundred are a hundred apart and so we
should consider them both equally similar and 20
and 22 are only two apart so they're very similar
but actually if we look at it in a log scale
we'll find that 20 and 22 and a thousand and 1100
are both equally different or equally
similar and 20 and 120 are much further apart
and because we're taking logs what
we end up measuring is the relative
difference between the values rather than
the absolute difference between the values
another way to say it is that 22 is only 10 more
than 20. 1100 is only 10 more than a thousand
and here's an example for house price prediction
we want to predict uh the house selling price v
we've got a record which in this
case just has two fields u1 and u2
u1 is the area in square feet
u2 is the number of bedrooms
we care about relative errors in price so we're
much more we can say if two house prices differ by
ten percent we will consider them as
similar um and uh that allows us to consider
uh a million dollars and one point
one million dollars is just as similar
as a hundred thousand dollars and a
hundred and ten thousand dollars um
and so we'll embed the price v as using psi
of v as log v and then we'll standardize
we also standardize the records u in particular
we stand aside standardize the fields u1 and u2
and we do that by subtracting the corresponding
means and dividing by the standard deviations
and the reason we do this is easy to see if
we consider having two different records so
we suppose i have a record u and a record
u-tilde and then i'd like to say well how
close are you in utila well let's just write that
down well then u minus u tilde the 2 norm squared
that's going to be equal to u 1 minus u 2
1 squared plus u 2 minus u tilde 2 squared
and so the first term in this is the
difference in the number of bedrooms
of house you and house utilde and the
second is the difference in the price
of house you and house utilita and both of
those quantities are squared and added up
of course the trouble is is that even a
very small change in price is going to swamp
a change in number of bedrooms and yet a change
in the number of bedrooms from three to four
could be hugely significant much more so than
a change in the price from 200 000 to 250 000.
so standardizing puts these two different fields
on equal footing within our embedded vector space
so then we're going to predict why y is log v
the log of the price from the standardized area
in the standardized number of bedrooms we'll
have a linear predictor which will be y hat
is theta 1 plus theta 2 x 1 plus theta 2
times x 2 plus theta 3 times x 2. i'm sorry
and so in terms of the original data we're going
to uh so how does this work we start off with a
a bunch of data which we use
in order to determine theta 1
theta 2 and theta 3. and then we get given a new
house that we've never seen before a new record
and that gives us a u1 and a u2 a number of
bedrooms and a square footage we take that number
of bedrooms and number of square footage and we
standardize them to get an x one and next two
we then apply our predictor y hat is theta one
plus theta two x one plus theta three x two to
get a y hat which is a prediction of the log
of the price and so our predicted price is
constructed by inverting that embedding y is log v
by to using v hat is the exponential of y so v hat
is going to be x of theta 1 plus theta 2 times u 1
minus mu 1 on sigma 1 plus theta 3 times u 2 minus
mu 2 and sigma 2. and this is very interpretable
um so for example if here theta 2 is 0.7
what does that mean well it means that every
time u1 increases by one standard deviation
that means the price of the
house is going to get multiplied
by the exponential of 0.7 which
is about 2 so every change in
u1 which i think is area yeah every change in area
by one standard deviation doubles the house price
let's look at some more complicated embeddings
where we take an individual
field and embed it as a vector
so we can embed a field into a vector xs5 view
and now x here lives in rk that's the dimension
in which that particular field is embedded and
it's useful to have a k which is more than one
even when the quantity that you're embedding the
raw data you is just a raw it's just a real scalar
we've already seen that with the polynomial
embedding where phi of u is one u u squared
up to u to the d and that's useful because it
allows us to use a linear predictor to construct
a predictor which is a non-linear function of u
even though the predictor
is a linear function of x
and there are other things you can do you can
similarly use other nonlinear functions you might
embed it as 1 u minus u plus it's worth drawing
what these functions are so let me try and do that
so this is going to be u and then
i'll plot the function use there
and i will also plot the function
0 which just sits right there and then u subscript
minus is the minimum of these two functions
which means that there is u subscript minus
and u subscript plus is the
maximum of these two functions
and so that means that this here
is u plus so i've got two functions we
think about u plus as being the positive
part of u and u minus as being the negative
part of u now what that means if i'm trying
going to construct a linear predictor with these
two features it means well let's write that down
uh let us
so i'm going to have a linear predictor
which is a function of these two features
i'm going to have y hat which is going to be
theta 1 plus theta 2 over u plus plus theta 3
of u minus and uh so this is a constant this is a
linear function of u on the positive part of when
u is greater than zero and it's a constant when
u is negative and this is a linear function of u
for when u is negative and it's a constant when
u is positive what that means is that my function
y hat
is a function of u i can plot
it and it will look something
like this it has a particular slope here a
particular slope here and a particular intercept
there and those three quantities are determined by
theta one theta two and theta three in particular
the intercept is theta one the
slope of this part of the line
is theta 2 and the slope of this part of the
line is theta 3. and so i have a piecewise
linear function
now it's also worth being aware that when one
talks about piecewise linear functions often one
thinks about that meaning a function where the
joint it is composed of linear segments and the
joins between the linear segments may be anywhere
and i may have any number of segments here
we're choosing predictors which are piecewise
linear functions but they're very specific
piecewise linear functions they only have two
linear pieces and the join has to
be at the origin join has to be
somewhere
there
this particular quantity the
the origin in this case is called a not for
this piecewise linear function that's a knot
and you might have more complicated piecewise
linear functions which you could construct
using a different embedding so for example if my
embedding was 1 u plus u minus and u minus 1 plus
well then there'd be an additional not out here at
1 when i'd be able to pick a different slope and
then slope would be determined by these additional
parameters well i've got four parameters theta
one theta two theta three and theta four it's
worth noticing also that the slope of this line
will not just be the coefficient in front
of u minus 1 plus but it will in fact be
the coefficient the sum of the coefficient of
u minus 1 plus and the coefficient of u plus
now then a particular type of data field is called
categorical and what that means is it only takes
a finite number of possible values in other words
the set script u is a finite set and we've called
the entries in that set alpha 1 up to alpha
k those are called the category labels
sometimes we'll use category labels 1
through k and we'll refer to category i
sometimes will be explicit about alpha 1
to alpha k and refer to category alpha i
depending on what works best at that particular
notational point lots of things are categorical
variables the most common is the boolean true
or false there's only two possible values
we might be trying to identify fruit in which case
we might have apple orange and banana we might
have a field which is the day of the week
in which case there are seven possible values
monday through sunday we might have zip codes
that's 40 000 possible values roughly um you
could just say well embed that as a real number
but then we'd ask the question well is that
faithful and we might conclude well there's
no particular reason why two zip codes that are
numerically close should be physically close
sometimes they are and sometimes they are not
uh countries of course they're not numerical
at all and so there are maybe about 180 or so
different countries that we might list
in just a bunch of different categories
uh languages there are several
thousand different languages
um at least those which are
spoken by a large number of people
now there's a particular way of embedding
categoricals which is very common and very useful
and that's called the one hot embedding so
let's just refer to our categories now as
one through k so that script u is has k positive
it consists of the numbers one two k any the value
of the field is either going to be 1 or 2 or up
to k so the one hot embedding says if you see
u is equal to i then embed that as e subscript
i remember what e subscript i is so in
a vector space e 1 is just the vector
1 0 0 e 2 is just the vector 0 1 0 0
e 3 is the vector 0 0 one zero and so on people
call it the e i the eighth canonical basis vector
in a vector space and so in a k dimensional
vector space there are k different canonical basis
vectors and so we can embed the categories one
through k as the k different basis vectors in rk
so in particular we might
embed apple as one zero zero
orange as zero one zero
and banana as zero zero one
we might embed true as one zero and false as
zero one and this is a different embedding of the
booleans into r2 this time as opposed to the minus
one one embedding we saw earlier we might embed
languages there's a bunch of different canonical
basis vectors uh all the way up to 185 of them
um and if we uh standardize these features well
that allows us to handle unbalanced data because
when we standardize these features they
won't remain at one zero zero zero one
zero zero zero one they will get shifted by
the mean and scaled by the standard deviation
and in particular the mean and the
standard deviation of the data set
will be affected by the proportions of the
different categories that show up in the data set
and that's a nice way of
handling unbalanced data sets
and we will see some of the problems that show
up with unbalanced data sets later in the class
there's also another way of doing uh one
hot embedding which is called reduced
one hot embedding and here the idea is is that
instead of it mapping the categories 1 through k
to k dimensional space we map them
to k minus 1 dimensional space
where we do this is we choose one
of the categories say the last one
category k as the default value the nominal
value and we embed that at the origin
all of the other categories 1 through k
minus 1 we embed as the first k minus 1
canonical basis vectors e
1 to e k minus 1 as before
if we do that for the booleans then we would
embed true as 1 and false as 0 because here k
is two there's only two categories and so r
k minus one is simply the real numbers and uh
so we're embedding booleans as one and zero and
this is a very common embedding of the booleans
there's another type of data a specific type
of categorical data and that's categorical data
that's ordered now apple pear banana are very much
not ordered quantities there's no natural order
to put the fruit in but very often you do have
uh orderings so for example when you uh uh give
something a rating on amazon and uh you're either
gonna give it one two three four or five stars and
yes there's only five possible categories that you
can put it in but those definitely have an order
such a scale where there's
uh an order to the categories
it is uh and it's used to indicate a preference is
called a leicard scale l-i-k-e-r-t um yeah so for
example uh the original leica scale was strongly
disagree disagree neutral agree or strongly agree
you know leica was actually a person it's not just
a scale it measures how much you like something
like was a psychologist an american
psychologist who lived in michigan
he lived for most of the 20th century the likert
scale can be embedded into the real numbers
with values minus two minus one zero one or
two and it's nice it's a faithful embedding
in the sense that it preserves the
ordering of the different categories
it's also quite reasonable to treat the lycra
scale as a categorical with one heart embedding
into our five um that way is perhaps a little
less faithful but both ways are very common
you can do the same thing with other
categoricals as well for example the
number of bedrooms in a house you could treat
it as a real number or you could treat it as an
ordinal with values between one and six
and both would be completely reasonable
so i want to talk right now about feature
engineering this is the next stage after embedding
so in embedding we're starting with
raw data and we are putting that data
into a vector space so that we can use
mathematics to develop machine learning algorithms
the next stage is to think about feature
engineering and in feature engineering the
basic idea is that we start with some features
and then we process or transform them to make new
engineered features and instead of just having a
predictor which is dependent of on the original
embedding we have a predictor which is in
bit which is dependent on these new features
uh we can do this in lots of different ways and
we've seen some ways already so one example of
this is where we used a polynomial embedding of a
real raw data we embedded it as one u u squared u
cubed and so on and you could either think about
that as an embedding or as feature engineering
where we've chosen features in a particular way
in the hope that it will improve our predictor
in that case what it does is it allows our
linear predictors to become polynomial predictors
now fundamentally the question you have to ask
yourself is what feature engineering should you
do does it improve the predictor um and
there's an answer to this question that
is worth repeating to yourself throughout this
class and and that is is that the way you tell
whether one predictor is better than another
is by validating the performance so if you want
to know whether these new features that you're
producing using feature engineering are helpful
are better than the original features then
develop a predictor using the original features
developer predictor using the new features in both
cases validate the performance against unseen data
if the performance with the new features is better
well then your feature engineering is actually
helpful and if it wasn't then you don't need to do
that particular piece of feature engineering and
look at something else the point is is that
there is no answer to this question there is
no answer to how one should embed a particular
type of data for a particular type of problem
the answer comes about through validation through
measuring the performance against a data set in
determining whether the performance is better with
that sort of features after the fact sometimes you
can come up with some post hoc explanation for
why certain features were better you can say
things like well obviously for numbers of bedrooms
one should use uh one hot embedding rather than uh
ordinal embedding into the reels but there's
no truth to such post-hoc explanations those
are just justifications for uh what happened with
the outcome that happened to turn out that way the
only test the only way of knowing whether one set
of features is better than another is to validate
there are several different types of feature
transforms one is to modify particular features
that you have so you've got a feature x i and you
replace it with an with a transformed feature of
x i new so you might standardize for example um
another thing you can do is you can say well
i've got one feature and i'm going to take that
one feature and can create multiple features
from it that's the power as example we take
x i we replace it with x i x i squared x i cubed
and so on another thing you can do is you can take
more than one feature and combine them together
to create new features so for example you can
take two features say x1 and x2 and create a new
feature which will be the product of x1 and x2
here's a feature that's very commonly used this
is the gamma transform you take x and you replace
it with sine of x multiplied by the absolute
value of x to the power of some constant gamma
and that produces curves that are shown in this
plot right here if gamma is a half for example
it produces a curve that looks like that
that's a case where we might believe for
example that a feature has diminishing
importance as its magnitude grows and so
we might replace it um we might replace x by
the absolute value of x to the power of a half
um again that's a justification but it doesn't
necessarily mean that if a feature has diminishing
importance then you should use the gamma transform
it's something reasonable to try particularly if
you're using a linear predictor but the only way
to know whether it's better or not is to validate
another thing you can do is clip this is also
called saturation or winds arising there's a nice
little formula for it here the new x is equal to
x if x is between l and u or it's equal to u when
x is greater than u or it's equal to l when x is
less than l and that saturized saturates like this
and so values larger than in this
case than one i just treat it as if
they're one values less than minus one
i just treat it as if they're minus one
we might believe that for example our data
contains anomalies very large data values
that are really a an artifact of the way
the data was measured and we know that
the physical quantity that's being
measured can never exceed values
of 1 or minus one in which case windsor
rising would be a reasonable thing to do
here's powers we've seen these already
this we know that this is u u squared
and u cubed
and here's one we've seen already as well u
plus and u minus these are splitting x into
uh positive and negative parts there's an
additional one here which is worth looking at
this is the saturation function sat of x sat of x
is the minimum of 1 the maximum of x and minus 1.
we can plot that let's try and do that
the maximum of x and minus 1 well this is the
minus 1 function and this is the x function
so the maximum of x and minus 1 is
that function right there and then we take the
minimum of that function and one and the one
function is right here and so the minimum
of those two functions is let me draw it
right here that's the sat function it's the
windsorization it's another way of expressing
the windsorization or the saturation
function that we saw over here
another thing one can do is create
new features for multiple features
so we can model interactions among features so
for example um you might create all products
x i x j or you might create the
maxima maximum of x i and x j
you can also create all the monomials of
degree 3 or less x1 x2 x1 squared x1 x2
and so on and that would give us an
arbitrary polynomial of degree 3.
products can be thought about as a nice way
of modeling interactions and so can maxima so
for example suppose x i are boolean so and
we've embedded them to take values 0 or 1.
they might represent say patient symptoms then we
create interaction features which are the products
of x i x j and of course we only need to
consider the terms which i is less than j
because x i x j is equal to x j x i
so there are going to be if we have
d original features we're going to add d times
d minus one divided by two additional features
then if we do linear regression
say when d is 3 we're going to get
an expression which looks like theta 1
x 1 plus theta 2 x 2 plus theta 3 x 3
plus theta 1 2 x 1 x 2 plus theta 1 3 x 1
x 3 plus theta 2 3 x 2 x 3 those would be
that would be the form of a linear
predictor with those new features
now these are very nicely interpretable these
coefficients because theta one is the amount
the prediction goes up when x one is one theta
two is the amount of production goes up when
x three is one and c two one three is the amount
the prediction goes up when both x1 and x3 are one
in addition to c to one and theta
three you get this additional boost
in your prediction and so this is
saying that when two symptoms both occur
then we believe our predicted value of whatever
it is we're predicting should have an additional
amount added to it c to one three another
way to say is that if theta 1 3 is large then
if you've got both symptoms simultaneously
present then we increase our estimate a lot
another thing one can do in future
engineering is quantization we specify
bin boundaries b1 to bk and we partition
the real numbers into buckets the interval
from b1 to b2 from b2 to b3 and so on
and then we replace x by the following we
embed it as e one through e k plus 1 where
the embedding returns e1 if
x1 is less than equal to b1
it returns e2 if x1 is in the next bin between b1
and b2 and so on so x maps to e i if x is in bin i
this is a one hot embedding of the ordinal that
results from figuring out which bin x is in
and you might say well why would you ever do
that and the answer to that kind of question
is always the same is that this is the kind
of thing you try and see whether it works
the only way to know whether or not it's better is
to try it and validate sometimes you may believe
that this the case where x is in these different
bins those are really different situations and so
the predictor should treat them differently and
introducing these kinds of features is one way to
develop a predictor that treats these different
cases differently that would depend on
what type of predictor you're using and uh so
it's a it's an intuitive motivation rather than a
rigorous motivation ultimately one validates to
determine whether or not such a prediction such a
piece of feature engineering is a good idea or
not now you can do these many times you don't
have to do embedding and then one round of feature
engineering you can compose them with each other
you start by embedding the original record u
into a feature vector which we'll call x0 and
then you transform x0 using a feature engineering
transform to get x1 that might be standardized
and then you repeat again you may do a polynomial
embedding or you might do binning or you might do
windsorization then you repeat this m times and
you've got a composition of different feature maps
and that gives you the final embedding this
is called the feature engineering pipeline
now there's one more topic that i want to mention
in this section and that's
automatic feature generation
so the features that we've seen so far are
generally done by hand using experience
and that's hard to do essentially it's done
when one's trying these kinds of things there
are things that one knows is are generally a good
idea standardization logarithms one hot embeddings
and there are things that one has experience of
in certain domains certain embeddings work well
in certain domains products for symptoms
for example is a very good thing to do
um and then there is the rest of
it which is largely trial and error
one can try a bunch of different
feature engineering tricks
and hope that they improve your validation
results and because it's trial and error it
would be very nice to be able to develop feature
mappings automatically directly from the data
and this is certainly possible we've
already seen two examples one is word to vec
where words were mapped to vectors another is
vgg16 where images were mapped to vectors and
those were learned and they would do so they were
developed automatically from very large data sets
and those are very important methods they have
made a huge difference to our ability to do
effective machine learning and we will see later
those methods in some detail and we'll talk about
some specific methods for constructing
these things pca is an example that stands
for principle component analysis
neural networks is another example
so to summarize all features are mapped to
vectors that's embedding it's the feature map
we subsequently process those vectors
in our predictor we may do extensive
feature engineering to construct more and more
complex ways of mapping features to vectors
only validation can choose between
different candidate feature maps
and we're going to see later how feature mappings
can be derived from data as opposed to by hand